people are saying that the United States
is ever more divided blah blah blah how
do you Sue this country Douglas well
it's obviously divided and wildly
divided and you you can't unless you
spend long periods of time here you
can't adjust how bad it is
one thing I would make observation on
that is in the time I've been coming
here myself I've noticed that
um
uh people used to talk about people who
had the means to move around which is of
course not everybody
people who have the means to move around
used to talk about moving abroad
if things go south in America
we know we'll go to New Zealand
it was a sort of dinner party
conversation if you like right what was
the other one Canada yeah remember that
yeah I mean none of these places have
made themselves remotely appealing in
the time since but I do notice that that
is that has disappeared pretty much as a
subject of conversation partly because
the way in which countries like
Australia New Zealand and Canada dealt
with lockdown and covert and showed
extraordinary authoritarian Tendencies
which most people hadn't expected
[Music]
um but it's also gone away because
what's happening in America is people
are moving within the country you know a
lot of my friends in California have
been moving to Texas particularly Austin
uh my friends in New York are mainly
left when I came here uh
um and they've moved to you know Houston
Miami and some of the wealth he wants to
move to Palm Beach or the West Palm
Beach and and you know Florida General
and some people see this as a terrible
sign an example of the further
fracturing of the society
um you can see it that way but you can
also see it as an expression of trust
nevertheless in the United States of
America or to put it another way the
recognition that if America goes south
you don't buy yourself any time in Malta
you know uh if America goes south you
don't actually buy yourself any time in
one of the countries that was
effectively protected as a satellite
part of the American era of of dominance
um so I think it's a sort of recognition
now of that if you don't save it here
it's not saved anywhere so you better
make sure it works here and and there
are people from the crazy extremes of
the left and the right in America most
recently on the right from the lunatic
congresswoman Marjorie Taylor green
who's the sort of gift that keeps on
giving for the Democrats
um who called for you know a split up of
the country uh
it's mad talk and frivolous talk really
but
um yeah it matters enormously that
people in America should be able to get
along and if they can't you know there
are many other problems that come from
that but I think that
I've said a lot whilst I've been here
that that people say so what one thing
can you do to to fix the the growing
divide and I always say you know just
agree on one thing
the one thing that happened I agree when
you were founded
you know or agree on
you know the availability of the
Constitution or just agree on the fact
the founding fathers of Great Men or
whatever you you want just like agree
that it was a good thing that Abraham
Lincoln was born you know whatever you
want just like or agree who won the last
election
that's a tougher one you know just that
would that would that would really help
in America because the problem as I said
quite often is that uh the problem is in
America in particular is not that people
have different opinions but they have
different facts and and you you find
very fast in any interaction in public
or private which facts the person you're
speaking to is God and the moment you
get into one of the ones they've got
which is one that you regard as not
being true
um you just get gnarled up
and you very rarely can get anywhere
after that you either have to park it
say okay let's just not do that now or
you have to go all in and you know
ruin the evenings
of a past Master yeah you know what when
you're talking about agreeing on
something all the things you listed are
important but I sort of feel it almost
goes deeper than that which is first and
foremost Americans and the West with
people in the Western countries
generally have to agree that we want the
West to survive like we want it to
prosper yeah and there's quite a lot of
people now who don't agree on that and
I'm not just talking about the crazies
on the left although that is primarily
coming from them but your point about
you know people saying we need a
national divorce all of that I mean part
of that is
a a an idea as you say is crazy talk
that would make sure that America
doesn't survive and doesn't prosper yeah
I mean the the problem is is that
everyone can only see the world from the
position they're standing in and
um there's a limited amount extent which
you can say to people you have no idea
how good you've got it I mean you've
both spoken about this before and we've
spoken about it
you can sort of tell people it's sort of
Hell over there or is Hell there before
or is it but people are just living in
the lives they've
found themselves in and if things aren't
always going their way they will quite
often reach for a grandiose overarching
explanation for it
um I mean the Oddity of course is that
they tend to reach back for explanations
that have failed every time they've been
tried you know like I remember after the
financial crisis in a way there was a
gloss of pieces by ignoramuses saying
things like
should we think about trying socialism
well as I should we look at
eating cyanide
but that's only because these are
ignorant people who think that there's a
sort of binary that's right which is
like capitalism when it's gone wrong
like it did in 2008.
and the only other alternative to
capitalism is
state-run communism so that's so again I
I don't have much time for those people
uh and well maybe we should sort of just
ignore them you know uh they just don't
know what they're talking about I mean
you you can't open your mouth and be
that stupid I think you should but this
is what I'm getting at though is I think
more broadly in society the very idea
you know how often do you hear on TV or
in the paper someone saying what you and
I have both said often which is the West
is great and we want it to survive and
throw
but that isn't something that people say
and I feel like quite a lot of people
don't actually have that Concept in mind
because they're so busy on the internal
fight they don't recognize that they're
external fights in which we are
weakening ourselves by fighting amongst
each other yeah I I I think it's partly
it goes back to the point I was making
about the mode as the vendy
um people don't necessarily understand
the settlement that they're living in
um
and that this might all be part of it or
at least this is the only system that
allows for that
um you know I mean
free market capitalism is the only
system anyone ever invented that makes
even its critics Rich you know as Mr
Chomsky and others have found out
um
uh Michael Moore is another good example
um but
I think a lot of people don't understand
the the the the mode in which the
society is set that allows for
self-criticism that allows for the
self-flagellation that that allows for
the endless
criticisms and critiques and my view is
that that's all actually a a feature of
our society which is good
the self-criticism is a definite benefit
in Western societies it's good until it
turns into self-laceration self-loathing
and then self-destruction
and it's not hard to see where those
degradations occur
um but
I I think that yes a lot of people don't
understand
the setting they're in or laminess of
like the fishing water thing you know
they just they don't realize that that's
the water
and the alternatives are all just being
flung out into a dry parched land I'm
um
but that maybe maybe this this stuff
only comes up because of sort of
frustrations that people are feeling and
and they grab for whatever there is that
they think is the only other
alternatives
unfortunately everything nearby that
they grab is so much worse as we all
know